joining me now is Newt Gingrich former
speaker of the house and Fox News
contributor new you did get the sense
um yesterday that there were a whole lot
of Democrats who were just a tad
disappointed that they didn't have that
scene I think that they were hoping for
of some type of unrest in the streets
well I look I think the Democrats were
desperate to have Trump behave in some
kind of angry hostile Manner and to have
him call out his supporters to recreate
a sense of you know civil unrest or Riot
or whatever in that sense I thought that
Trump was amazingly disciplined came
across exactly right
indicated clearly that he was
subordinate to the law and then while he
thought this whole indictment was
absurdity he nonetheless was not in any
way going to encourage people to go
outside the law then I thought his
speech last night was extraordinarily
well written and well delivered and
again it was it was a tone of
reasonableness a tone of talking about
the accurate history of the last couple
years and just how bad the left has been
so I think probably the left tonight is
a little frustrated because they may
begin to sink in them they may just have
guaranteed he'll be the Republican
nominee I mean when even Mitt Romney and
Jeb Bush and others come out and say
this is wrong you're seeing sort of a
consolidation of Trump versus a corrupt
establishment that could have huge
implications both for the nomination and
for the general election do you disagree
that the Democrats are going to make
this election in their mind not a
referendum on Biden which obviously has
to be but a referendum on Trump because
if it's a referendum on Biden it's hard
to see that they can win but if it's a
referendum on Trump they think they can
get enough of their same supporters out
to win in Pennsylvania win in Arizona
win in Georgia Etc
yeah look I mean I think if you're the
Democrats and you're looking at a failed
Biden Administration you're looking at
extremists in the House and Senate uh
you're looking at policies you can't
defend back home you need something to
take people's attention away from
reality the problem they've got is
normal everyday Americans sit down at
the kitchen table they look at their
family budget they look at the cost of
gasoline they look at the disaster on
the border they worry about crime in
their neighborhood none of those things
fit what the Democrats wish they were
focused on and I think frankly the more
calm and the more reasonable the Trump
is the harder the Democrats problem is
that's why I thought yesterday was a
very significant moment he didn't rant
and Rave he didn't try to arouse his
supporters he very calmly went into
court he very calmly gave a talk that
was disciplined and orderly
if he strips away the weaknesses they
want to attack the Democrats have
nothing left to campaign on
well yesterday
um the JP Morgan
um CEO Jamie dimon released his annual
report to shareholders Newt and here's
how ABC News reported it diamond is
optimistic about the economy despite
recession fears positives are huge well
note ABC must have glossed over the
section of the report entitled
evaluating and managing the economic and
geopolitical risks
and it reads that the current economy is
pretty good but storm clouds ahead
potential trouble Brewing from
unprecedented fiscal spending
quantitative tightening and geopolitical
tensions preparing for what may be a new
and uncertain future
Newt uh they are desperate in the media
to try to Rebrand this economy as
evolving
and not
slowing
look I think you have to start with the
idea that the elite media is simply the
publicity arm of the Biden
Administration they are pure propaganda
they have no interest in the facts
remember the New York Times The
Washington Post got Pulitzer prizes for
reporting total falsehoods about what
turned out to be the Russian hoax and
they didn't give back their Pulitzer
prizes they were quite happy to keep
them so you just have to start every
morning with the idea these are the
equivalent of Pravda and azvestia in the
old Soviet Union they're the party line
they tell you what they want you to
believe but the average American goes
out and they look at reality they go to
the grocery store they go to the gas
station they look at the crime rate in
their City they look at them I know I
know but that's the Border release dude
I don't mean to interrupt you but they
looked at that in in 2022 and they
elected John Federman and they elected
Katie Hobbs in Arizona so in two years
we got to get enough of those voters to
switch and become Republicans yes
sure because it was bad it was bad last
November too
look I think the key to that is to
recognize that our Consultants are
mostly totally out of touch with reality
they're running obsolete campaigns
everywhere the Republicans ran positive
campaigns with Positive Solutions like
in Iowa and Florida they won huge
landslides
all right new great to see you tonight
as always hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else